if you can go back just look at the
entirety of your life you accomplished
more than most humans will ever do if
you could go back and relive a single
moment in your life what would that
moment be there are moments in my life
when I think about what could be done
differently but no experience happiness
and joy and pride just-just-just is this
it's the it's look I made many mistakes
in my life so I just it's there I know
that at the end of the day it's I
believe in the butterfly effect so is
the it's the I knew moments where I
could now you find there at that point
in 89 in 93 you pick up a year I could
improve my actions by not doing this
stupid thing but then how do you know
that I will have all other
accomplishments I just I'm I'm afraid
that you know we just have to just
follow this if you make always there
before is Gumpy know it's the life as
this you know it's this it's a box of oh
yeah of chocolate and you don't know
what's inside but you have to go one by
one so it's the I'm I'm happy with who I
am and where I am today and I am very
proud not only with my chess
accomplishments but that I made this
transition and since I left chess you
know I built my own reputation that had
some influence of the game of chess but
not it's not you know directly derived
from from the game I'm grateful for my
wife so who helped me to build his life
we actually married in 2005 it was my
third marriage that's why I said that
made mistakes in my life but I never by
the way I'm close with two kids from my
previous marriages so that's tasty I
mean I managed to sort of to balance my
life and and here it I live in New York
so we have our two kids born here in New
York it's its new life and it's you know
it's it's busy sometimes I wish I could
you know I could limit my engagement in
many other things that said I still you
know
[Music]
taking time and energy but life is
exciting and as long as I can feel that
I've energy I have strength
I've passion to make the difference I'm
happy
you